at first Lee had me playing an angel I  said an angel that means I'm over you  know I'm gone she said okay Lola I'm  gonna give you a part you're gonna come  back all the time so Patti LaBelle will  return no he had me singing this  beautiful song I said I wanna sing that  beautiful song let me just come back so  I'll be back so you love  oh yes and Debbie Allen she directed my  episode and we worked together years ago  you know and it was fun you know with  Jamal and all the people on on Empire  it's a great show one of the best that's  a bunch of old Patti in there you know  what cookie said to me again back in the  day  taraji she said when I grow up I want to  be just like you that was like ten years  ago and then she saw me on Empire she  said I'm still gonna be like you when I  grow up so she's my daughter  you